The joe rogan experience.
Uh,
Wyclef Jean who just robbed half
a fucking Haiti dot cock sucker.
That's why I'm Haiti.
You to see that he robbed us all.
Fucking earthquake relief.
Fun.
No,
that million dollars brow.
That's why I'm saying unless I see
the guy on the street bleeding,
I give them money.
When you sent her flowers,
they get 30 of it.
Did you steal my change jar in the late
nineties probably fucking change jar.
What's a change jar?
Is this the head?
Oh,
if blue just talking about Robert.
Yeah,
he was just thinking about the nineties
and we where we lived on curse on and
there was a fucking change.
Our Ego that probably is fucking,
I called you Joey jingles for awhile.
No,
no.
I would never write change.
I know that it was someone
who just fucking change.
Just like a fucking cup of cheese.
Yeah.
It was just a weird thought
at this point in my ankle,
I smoked pot,
which I never do.
A fuck is wrong with y'all.
I'm a professional.
Yeah.
Now I remember calling
Seattle one time.
I was opening up for a stay at
home and I picked him up in an Rv.
It was snowing in Seattle.
I know weird chick was her puppy Carroll,
the white stuff.
The fucking a little before Perez.
He was around for that.
He knew all about that shit.
See how Joe Rogan,
you could go crazy.
You got a chick that's sucking your Dick.
I've got no experience with this cocaine.
I don't,
I don't have any experience.
We have a fucking shady job.
Jesus.
No,
no,
no.
I just noticed the fucking,
all the chains had been taken
out and nothing else was stolen.
I go,
who would do that?
And I go,
I think Joey's back on drugs.
Maybe you fucking so I called Joe Doe.
It's impossible.
Joe,
you might've done it.
Forgot about it.
I think the last time I went to Stan hope
sounds like someone like I had an open
house policy.
He had an open house policy.
Still do.
I'm like,
who would just like,
I was just going,
this is the fucking like
1996 we were all broke.
I'm going,
which one of my friends would be
broken enough to just fucking,
I have a thought of you.
I was at the coach and horses tangles out
of my fucking mind and I couldn't walk
to,
uh,
Vista.
So I went to [inaudible] because he had
the open door policy and I go to stay at
hopes,
I hope with the go.
He's got the bunk beds I get on.
But no,
at this time it was the living room.
He just had a cut.
I get on the car cause I couldn't even
make it to the fucking bed tonight
there's an earthquake and I wake up
to the house and they opened my eyes
sideways and I see the clock.
So I'm focusing on the clock,
but the fucking earth is moving,
you know what I'm saying?
And that was just,
that's I think the last time I was.
Do you still have that apartment?
It's subsidized rent control.
I still live there all the time.
I still beat the horn when I go by like
a motherfucker Hennigan's now just kinda
give him town.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Do you ever Miss La?
Yeah.
Now.
Right now the fucking
drive here was horrific.
I was going to change I,
I was trying to get ahold of you.
If,
if we have to do this the next
day I'm going to change my flight.
I'm like,
I can just fly.
I could fucking 10 days off.
I'll just fly to fucking somewhere.
I never do that.
Just fly somewhere for a vacation.
I had my passport in Costa Rica.
If I'm going to extend my stay here,
did fucking hang out with you.
I'll probably be fucked up when I leave.
Why not?
And then just the thought of lax
fucking ruined that entire fantasy.
Really?
Oh,
sorry.
He's going to talk down here.
No,
it was perfect.
All right,
that's fine.
Well,
my audio functions are way fucked.
Oh yeah,
I'm medicinally.
You know what I'm,
why did you move there in the first place?
Why did you decide to,
you live in Bisbee Arizona
in the middle of nowhere,
right?
What was the,
just wanted to get away
and Paul's by as a place,
I've found what I was driving on the road.
I really impulse buy.
Yeah.
I didn't even see the inside.
Did you know anything
about the town pictures?
Did you know anything about the town?
I had been there a lot.
Sorry.
I had a fucking,
it's fine dude.
Yeah,
yeah,
no.
Alright.
Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo.
So,
um,
yeah,
so I've,
what's the downside?
What's the downside of living
in a tiny little town like that?
Cause you're in like a town of like what?
6,000 people or something crazy.
Yeah.
Jake Lamata has come over
to the house a couple times.
Jake Lamata the fighter.
Yeah.
Really?
The Guy who they made the
movie regional bullet about.
Yeah.
What's that guy like?
Uh,
you know what?
I could do a fucking 20 minute bit.
That's the downside.
Like he,
he lives there.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
but you have to be respectful
of people there because like
any good story that comes out of there,
of course your neighbor.
That's the downside of
living in a small town.
Yeah.
You can't talk about camp.
Flip someone off half the fucking
stop sign because they cut you off.
Cause that guy will be behind you
in line it fucking safe safely.
Yeah.
Like how often you run into the
same people over and over again?
All the time.
Yeah.
That's a weird thing,
huh?
I go,
yeah.
You get a fucking really funny
fucking bit about your neighbor.
So do you guys think that geography
is took care of his change real quick?
No,
I don't think there's this spot.
Yeah.